and as you say Odessa was the latest
strike by the Russian missiles the total
of debtors increasing all the time at
the moment Ukraine's claim they shot
down two of the four missiles that came
over but it's pretty evident from the
destruction we're seeing and for the
video footage on the ground that some um
got through uh also overnight the
Russians also struck uh at crematorius
there were two people killed at
chromatosk over here and costianti binka
another uh person died there with
another strike this unfortunately
follows the night previously creepy rear
was also struck with the biggest attack
we've seen for quite some time actually
this is the home of President zielinski
and actually there were 12 deaths 30
injured 127 properties that were damaged
as part of this strike again none of
these appear to be military targets it's
either Russia trying to Target Russian
Logistics and rear support
infrastructure or which looks more
likely just a blatant continuation of
the attacks on the civilian population
of Ukraine
and Sean Belarus is threatened to enter
this conflict if there is aggression
against it why is President lukashenka
saying this now do we think it's
fascinating listening to president
lukashenko on state TV he said that he
had received some of the nuclear
missiles though coming in he said he
wouldn't hesitate to use them if he had
the chance if he was threatened um he
has been described as a last dictator in
Europe and it does feel like the uh
rhetoric of a man who's got a set of new
toys bluntly
um let's really be clear here President
Putin made quite clear when he said he
was moving missiles that Russia would
retain control of them these have
complex codes there's complex processes
for launching them there's almost no way
that President lukashenko will ever have
the chance to have a uh his hands on the
trigger now on face value these
announcements are more just to remind
the west of the threat of nuclear
escalation in Ukraine but the harsh
reality is that moving these weapons
forwards to Belarus makes no difference
at all to their utility around Ukraine
what it does make a difference for is
with those missiles into Belarus go a
whole load more Russians soldiers and
once again it's it's pretty clear that
Russia is struggling to subjugate
Ukraine militarily but it's absolutely
doing an invasion of Belarus by Stealth
at this time
how important do we now think air
support is going to be in deciding who
comes out on top on this conflict
it's an interesting question at the
moment because overnight we've been
trying to keep track of progress of the
Ukrainian counter-offensive ukrainians
claim they've taken a few settlements
Russia claimed they pushed back
um and it but it but it's certainly no
breakthrough at the moment but what we
are seeing is very hard yards from
ukrainians they're up against
established Uh Russian defenses and
we're now seeing an increased use of the
Russian Air Force using their frog foot
aircraft as shown here doing close air
support now it's worth remembering that
the West when we go into battle we will
try and establish air superiority first
because it's incredibly debilitating
being attacked by your enemy aircraft on
the ground now of course Ukraine don't
have that luxury and therefore they
don't aren't able to establish their
superiority and they are being attacked
from the air which has raised questions
of whether the West should have got
f-16s shown here into Ukrainian hands
earlier now in in as a former fighter
pilot myself just giving them f-16s
would not have changed the balance of
this war but if there had been some
available for this stage of the conflict
it would certainly give them the Russian
Air Force a little bit more to think
about rather than just attacking the
Ukrainian forces as they're on attack